the 2019 iPad air has just been released
but there's a problem it's basically the
2017 10.5 inch iPad pro but with the
newer processor in a few missing
features for almost as much cash and
we've seen the 2017 pro for as low as
$400 on Amazon even cheaper than the air
so make sure to check the links in the
video description to see if it's still
on sale so what's the difference in how
do you choose well let's compare them on
the back side they look almost identical
except that the old pro has a camera
bump in flash on the top edge you'll
find two extra speakers on the pro which
is the biggest reason to get the pro
instead we also get the same smart
connector on the side of each iPad for
the smart Keyboard on the front they
look literally identical they get the
same resolution same laminated display
same true tone and p-3 white color gamut
but the air is actually missing pro
motion technology what this means is
that it allows the display to refresh at
up to 120 Hertz and dynamically go down
to match the frame rate of the content
you're viewing to save battery life as
you can see in the slow-mo clip of the
2018 iPad pro in 2019 iPad air the
difference in smoothness of pro motion
compared to the air is huge and trust me
you'll feel this difference every day
not only that but promotion lowers the
latency of the Apple pencil as well and
you can easily see the difference
compared to the iPad air which doesn't
have it the 2017 iPad pros display also
gets brighter at 600 nits compared to
500 on the new air so that means it
supports HDR video now let's listen to a
quick sound comparison between these two
iPads make sure to put on some
headphones
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as you guys heard most of the sound is
coming from the right side on the air so
you get a much better listening
experience on the pro not to mention
actual stereo separation in landscape
mode this is going to be huge if you're
into gaming allowing you to hear
footsteps around you in shooting games
before we compare performance and gaming
let's compare the cameras the 2017 iPad
pro actually has a better rear camera
than the air at 12 megapixels instead of
8 this means you can take better photos
and shoot 4k video here's a quick photo
comparison so you can see the difference
getting into performance the 2019 iPad
air gets the new 812 processor from the
iPhone 10s complete with the knurl
engine in the 2017 iPad pro gets an
older a 10x chip but the pro actually
gets 4 gigabytes of RAM compared to
three on the new air comparing Geekbench
for scores the air is 22% faster in
single core than 21% faster in
multi-core which is definitely a
difference but not that much
comparing the metal graphics performance
test the old iPad pro is actually 35%
faster than the new air which affects
gaming performance more than processor
performance does now testing the antutu
benchmark the new air is now 35 percent
faster than the old pro a pretty good
difference we decided to run a more
realistic test by exporting a one-minute
4k HD VC video and the iPad air finished
18 seconds sooner than the old pro which
is surprisingly not that big of a
difference now let's compare gaming
performance playing Fortnight both iPads
can play at 60 frames per second but the
old pro is limited to medium graphics in
the setting while the new air can run 60
FPS on high settings in game both of
them are incredibly smooth and
responsive with no noticeable drop
frames at 60fps the biggest difference I
noticed was actually the speaker's it
was hard to hear footsteps on the air
with speakers only on one side so it
seems like the air is going to have
better gaming performance with higher
settings in certain games but both iPads
run games perfectly the
air also gets newer cellular and
wireless tech like Bluetooth 5.0
simultaneous dual-band Wi-Fi and gigabit
class LTE so here's the question since
you can find the 2017 iPad pro for five
hundred to five hundred seventy dollars
brand new or for only four hundred
dollars refurbished on Amazon is the
extra performance of the 2019 iPad air
worth missing out on the iPad pros
awesome promotion of Technology and
forced speaker audio in my opinion no
going back to a non-pro ipad feels
really weird because it's missing
promotion it feels like the processor is
slow when it really isn't same for the
speakers once you experience four
speakers on the pro it's really hard to
go back in my opinion those features
make the 2017 10.5 inch iPad pro a much
better value than the air as long as you
can find it on sale below $600 which it
currently is on Amazon so make sure you
use the links in the video description
below the only caveat is that the pro
will lose software support in five years
instead of seven on the air but when
that happens if you do wait that long to
upgrade your iPad you won't really mind
since you use the pro motion tech and
better speakers for all of those years
if you enjoyed this comparison click
that subscribe button thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]